Hyman wohlgemerkt mit c am anfang an sprechen sehen hören verstehen und fliegen und seit wenigen
tagen ist er der neue mitbewohner und sauber kollege von alexander gerst auf der raumstation iss
samen ist ein autonom agierender astronauten assistent und mit künstlicher intelligenz
ausgestattet und soll an bord demonstrieren wie eine zusammenarbeit von menschen und intelligenten maschinen
zukünftig gestaltet werden könnte was hat sein und auf dem kasten
wie genau kann er gast und kolleginnen und kollegen unter die arme greifen will ist dass die raumfahrt der zukunft jetzt wirklich zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
Der private raumfrachter dragon von ihnen us firma spacex war ende juni richtung iss gestartet
mit im gepäck waren nicht nur verpflegung und technische geräte sondern auch der neue cyber kollege für alexander gerst und
kolleginnen und kollegen der roboter seinen zeilen steht für crew
interactive mobile companion und wird somit zum 17 kopf der besatzung dabei ist er nur etwa so groß wie ein
medizinball genauso rund wiegt auf der erde 5 kilogramm und hat einen durchmesser von 32 cm
diamond ist damit weltweit der erste fliegende und autonom agierende astronauten assistent
ausgestattet mit
künstlicher intelligenz sein vorbild stammt aus der zeichentrickserie captain future
nämlich das fliegende gehirn ausgestattet mit einem sprachprozessor
kameras und sensoren und dem namen professor steven wright doch diese science fiction ist jetzt tatsächlich
realität entwickelt und gebaut wurde der roboter in deutschland und zwar vom deutschen zentrum für luft- und raumfahrt dlr
dazu der projektleiter christian karas heimen ist in dieser form weltweit
einzigartig dieses experiment soll zeigen wie weit es möglich ist die astronauten im
europäischen columbus modul der einst es bei ihren arbeiten zu unterstützen
und sie vor allem bei routineaufgaben zu entlasten im idealfall könnten die astronauten dadurch ihre zeit noch besser und effektiver
nutzen wir betreten hier neuland und bewegen uns mit seilen an der schwelle des
technologisch machbar dabei muss man wissen dass die technik an bord der iss ziemlich veraltet ist sie wurde vor jahrzehnten
entwickelt und ansonsten sind da einige laptops die struktur des neuen server kollegen wurde in einem 3d verfahren gedruckt sie
besteht aus kunststoff und metall ein display stellt sein gesicht da und dieses soll sich immer auf augenhöhe der
astronautinnen und astronauten bewegen und zwar schweben zwei kameras dienen als seinen augen eine weitere kamera kümmert sich um die funktion der gesichtserkennung
und zwei weitere kameras sind für die videodokumentation und zusatzfunktionen wie augmented reality
eingebaut seine ohren bestehen aus acht mikrofonen und ermöglichen zusammen eine richtungs und
spracherkennung und nicht andauernd gegen andere dinge oder menschen zu stoßen gibt es außerdem eine kollision erkennung die mit ultraschallsensoren
funktioniert über seinen lautsprecher mund kann er sprechen oder musik spielen trainiert werden kann er nur durch menschen
selbstständiges lernen steht dagegen nicht auf seiner agenda insgesamt 14 interne propeller machen ihn beweglich in alle möglichen
raumrichtungen wenn er angesprochen wird wendet er sich seinen gesprächspartner zu nickt und schüttelt mit dem kopf und folgt auf
kommandos in der schwerelosigkeit an bord der iss kann er bis zu zwei stunden im einsatz sein doch wie genau
kann er der iss-crew bei ihrer arbeit helfen
er dient als komplexe datenbank für alle arbeiten auf der ss und kann zudem als mobile kamera eingesetzt werden durch siemens
anwesenheit haben die astronauten bei ihrer arbeit beide hände frei denn sie müssen dann die computer nicht mehr manuell bedienen mit der tastatur
irgendwas suchen sondern stattdessen können sie
sprachgesteuert zugriff auf alle dokumente
und medien bekommen und außerdem auch die
anweisungen für bedienungs und reparatur prozesse an bord alexander gerst soll insgesamt drei mal mit seinem neuen cyber kollegen
zusammenarbeiten
unter anderem steht ein medizinisches experiment auf der agenda bei der der roboter als fliegende kamera genutzt hat
das projekt soll zeigen wie künstliche intelligenz menschen in solch einem komplizierten umfeld wie immer an bord der
internationalen raumstation der ss
unterstützen kann langfristig gesehen so als sei man nach dem plan seines entwicklungsteams noch weitere talente
hinzubekommen dazu der projektleiter till eisenberg
mittelfristig wollen wir uns auch gruppen effekten widmen die sich bei kleinen teams über lange zeit hinweg
entwickelt und bei langzeit missionen zum mond und mars auftreten können denn die soziale interaktion zwischen mensch und maschine
zwischen astronaut und mit emotionaler intelligenz
ausgestatteten flugbegleiter könnte eine wichtige rolle für den erfolg
dieser missionen spiel auch in sachen big data also riesiger datenmengen und ihrer verarbeitung
data mining soll weiter geforscht werden
langfristig sollen solche cyber kollegen die crew an bord auch medizinisch gesehen entlasten denn die schwerelosigkeit
fordert tribut vom menschlichen körper der kollege sei man könnte vor allem in sachen stress und zeitdruck eine große hilfe sein
scheinen könnte also zu einem zentralen bestandteil zukünftiger
raumfahrt missionen werden wie zum beispiel zum mars ja wenn ihr keine videos dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
endet mich bei whatsapp dann und geht in die kaputte abo boxee auf youtube und verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp
erfahrt ihr von mir noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich und garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und am besten
auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks zum social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt
dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
genauen vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit darf auch draufklicken 1000 raketen zum master könnte dann vielleicht
heimen auch eingesetzt werden bis dann
bleibt dran